vous êtes entrés dans le cœur des
Québécois il y a 10 ans avec la finale
de Star Academy ça va faire 10 ans en
rétrospective cette aventure là ce que
c'était comme gagné à la loterie oh mon
Dieu c'était comme
c'est comme c'était vraiment un rêve de
jeunesse le type parce que moi j'ai
écouté toutes les éditions par
académiques mon père ça rappelle encore
ce que je lui disais et moi je vais
faire Star Academy c'est ça
le début c'était mon école moi j'ai pas
suivi de cours de chant ou autre j'ai
rencontré plein de personnalités j'ai
vraiment appris l'assidu
pour moi c'était mon école c'était
vraiment une école
[Rires]
[Musique]
on la connaît vous êtes né en Haïti vous
êtes arrivés au Québec à un an plus tard
grosso modo et puis c'est un peu le
décès de votre maire adopté vous aviez
10 ans qui vous a vraiment poussé à
faire de la musique est-ce que pour vous
la musique c'est un symbole de
résilience ben en tout cas du plus tôt
que je me souviens moi je voulais être
une danseuse derrière ok donc là encore
là il y avait de la musique mais c'était
pas
c'était pas concret que j'avais une voix
mes parents ma famille me disent que je
chantais tout le temps mais pour moi
c'est vraiment venu après le décès et
même encore plus loin au secondaire avec
la chorale de l'école que là je me suis
dit ok je vais peut-être quelque chose
les professeurs m'ont entendu ils m'ont
dit ouais il y a une voix tu préfères
quelque chose de positif avec ça puis
c'est comme ça que ça commençait
[Musique]
alléluia
ça fait tellement longtemps que je
voulais vous rencontrer parce que tout
le monde me dit ah tu vas voir Mélissa
better extraordinaire toujours de bonne
humeur toujours gentil super généreuse
il vient d'où ce rayon de soleil là
pourquoi vous êtes comme ça parce que ça
c'est une bonne question
c'est que je sais parce que j'étais
adopté enfin je le sais que j'aurais pu
ne pas avoir tout ça je pense vraiment
que ça vient du fait que je me remets
toujours en tête je me suis très
terre-à-terre qui se rappelle que à qui
tu aurais pu être en Haïti dans la
misère mais notre état d'opté on te
donne une voix en plus de ça qui permet
que tu peux aider les autres peut-être
mettre en lumière d'autres mondes avec
d'autres projets c'est ce qui me pose à
choisir des projets aussi qui font du
bien qui qui aide les gens le partage
tout ça
mais ça Bédard vous êtes marre de trois
filles belle-mère de trois garçons on
peut voir dans l'émission ma première
maison oui comment faites-vous la
conciliation travail famille une art
c'est un travail à temps plein déjà là
vraiment c'est vraiment à temps plein
puis encore là dans les malheurs là
c'est avec la covid qui était négative
on a créé du beau calme mon mari devenu
papa à la maison enfin que ça fait en
sorte que je peux faire les contrats que
je veux te dire oui plus souvent ça me
casser la tête ça m'inquiéter de mes
enfants je sais que sont en train de
bonnes mains que papa puis pour les
autres c'est moins déstabilisant aussi
que de voir toujours les deux parents
partir le matin travailler puis même
elle revient pas le soir je suis beau
je veux parler de grossophobie parce que
vous avez abordé ce thème là vraiment
sensible dans la belle série je t'aime
grosse Siri essentiel que vous coignez
ouais avec Christine Morency a l'air des
réseaux sociaux
ça peut devenir compliqué parce que là
il y a même des gens qui vous espionnent
et qui surveille votre poids en ligne
donc c'est vrai mais ça ça fait une
sagace pour un pour un beau veston
finalement on le vendu beaucoup plus de
veste là mais comment vous vivez ça
c'est que je me suis rendu compte que
peu importe le qu'on soit gros qu'on
soit mince qu'on soit
peu importe la différence on va toujours
se comparer je me donne comme mission
d'en parler dans montrer moi ce Spora ou
là qu'on va me voir dans les centres
d'achat pour maquiller le mec avec la
perruque un peu croche c'est moi dans la
vie
[Musique]
Fabiola dans m'entendu quelle série
extraordinaire qui a eu trois saisons de
ça comment ça a changé aussi votre
carrière seront là parce que là on a vu
la mise à Médor interprète mais là
vraiment comédien mais comment on
devient comédienne jour au lendemain
c'est un moi j'ai toujours que avant et
après m'entendu je suis tombé en amour
avec la Fabiola parce que j'avais
l'impression que la médecine s'arrête
c'est la mission un peu plus parfaite
elle veut pas dépassé ses bords à vue
bien faire pour arriver à devenir
quelqu'un dans le moule fabiologue
permettait de retrouver la Mélissa jeune
maman d'un enfant qui n'a pas eu facile
qui qui est rocher pour y arriver
ça le fait de sortir mon naturel tout
simplement puis ça ça la série tellement
marcher mais après je me suis dit je
peux pas remettre un masque pour faire
assemblant que ma vie a toujours été
parfaite puis d'un autre côté ma vie est
parfaite fait en sorte ma vie est
parfaite qui est maintenant pas parfaite
mais qui maintenant bien va inspirer
d'autres gens qui ont une vie pour eux à
leurs yeux pas parfaite à devenir plus
MELS
[Musique]